Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is ther, the spectre of communism. All the powers of old Europe have entered into a holy alliance to exorcise this spectre. So begins the Communist Manifesto, written in 1848 by Karl Marx and Friedrich Engels. Welcome to The Rest Is History with me, Dominic Sandbrook, well-known Marxist, and my sidekick, wishy-washy Brixton centrist liberal Tom Holland. Hello, comrade.
感谢您收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。如需每周额外剧集、无广告收听、抢先观看系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。那就是“共产主义的幽灵”。旧欧洲的一切势力都已联合起来，对这个幽灵进行神圣的围剿。这就是《共产党宣言》的开篇，由卡尔·马克思和弗里德里希·恩格斯于1848年撰写。欢迎收听《历史的余味》，我是多米尼克·桑德布鲁克，一位众所周知的马克思主义者，还有我的搭档，那位优柔寡断的布里克斯顿中间派自由主义者汤姆·霍兰。你好，同志。
Hello, comrade. So today we're talking about communism, the great political theory that dominated so much conversation in the late 19th and much of the 20th centuries. And actually looking back, Tom, when we were kids, communism and capitalism are locked in this genuine competition, so it seemed, for the hearts and minds of millions of people. I mean, when you survey the world, the map, I can remember those maps from my kind of childhood. The Soviet Union and all its satellite states, Czechoslovakia, Yugoslavia,and hungary east germany and so on you had in africa you had places like angola ethiopia mozambique you had afghanistan mongolia of course the people's republic of china which is still technically communist as are cuba vietnam and laos but there's been a huge falling off since then so do you think communism is is gone or is it
你好，同志。所以今天我们要谈论的是共产主义，这种伟大的政治理论在19世纪末和20世纪的大部分时间里主导了如此多的讨论。说实话，汤姆，回想我们小时候，共产主义和资本主义似乎在为数百万人的心灵而进行着真正的竞争。我的意思是，当你审视世界地图时，我还能想起童年时看到的那些地图。苏联及其所有卫星国，捷克斯洛伐克、南斯拉夫、匈牙利、东德等等；在非洲，你有安哥拉、埃塞俄比亚、莫桑比克；还有阿富汗、蒙古，当然还有中华人民共和国，它在技术上仍然是共产主义国家，古巴、越南和老挝也是如此，但从那时起已经有了巨大的衰落。所以你认为共产主义已经消失了吗，还是它
still with us i think it's such a potent idea and it won't surprise you to know why I think it's a potent idea. I can't wait for this. I think it has very, very deep roots and maybe we'll come to that. And I think that the guiding kind of ideal that it embodies, that all of humanity can be liberated and that all of humanity can share in an equal justice is one that has an obvious appeal. And I guess that when we talk about communism, we tend to mean the specific form that it has taken in the writings of Marx
仍然伴随着我们？我认为这是一个非常有力的思想，而且你不会惊讶于我知道为什么我认为它是一个有力的思想。我迫不及待想听听这个。我认为它有着非常、非常深厚的根源，也许我们会谈到这一点。而且我认为它所体现的指导性理想，即全人类都可以获得解放，全人类都可以共享平等的正义，这具有明显的吸引力。我想，当我们谈论共产主义时，我们倾向于指它在马克思著作中所采取的具体形式，
and then the way that it's evolved with Lenin and with Mao and through the ideological war of the 20th century, as you said. But I do absolutely think that, I mean, it's, you know, China, potentially the greatest power on the face of the planet, remains a communist state. So it's ridiculous to say that, you know, communism has gone the way of Nineveh and Tire, simply purely on the political level. But I think it also continues to have a huge influence on the on the cultural level um yeah so i would say that uh that probably the the the two most influential communist thinkers at the moment would be antonio gramsky italian um in the writing in the 30s who um argued that essentially kind of culture is the way for social justice to be established.
以及后来它随着列宁和毛泽东的发展，以及通过你所说的20世纪意识形态战争而演变的方式。但我绝对认为，我的意思是，你知道，中国，可能是地球上最伟大的力量，仍然是一个共产主义国家。所以说共产主义已经像尼尼微和泰尔那样消失了，这在纯粹的政治层面上是荒谬的。但我认为它在文化层面上也继续产生着巨大的影响。嗯，是的，所以我会说，目前两位最有影响力的共产主义思想家可能是安东尼奥·葛兰西，意大利人，他在30年代写作，他认为文化本质上是建立社会正义的途径。
And that's been hugely influential in all kinds of ways that people understand the operation of culture. kind of articulated a Marxist understanding of world politics with an emphasis on how colonized societies and the global South can fight back against what he casts as oppressive imperial domination. And I would say that both of those thinkers have a colossal influence. I mean, I go so far as to say that actually, in a way, you could say that Marxism is more influential at the moment in the United States than it is in China. Discuss. That's interesting. That's an interesting argument. But they're both offshoots, aren a way, you could say that Marxism is more influential at the moment in the United States than it is in China. Discuss. That's interesting. That's an interesting argument.
这在人们理解文化运作的各种方式上产生了巨大的影响。他以一种马克思主义的方式阐述了世界政治，强调被殖民社会和全球南方国家如何能够反击他所称的压迫性帝国统治。我会说这两位思想家都有巨大的影响。我的意思是，我甚至会说，实际上，在某种程度上，你可以说马克思主义目前在美国比在中国更有影响力。讨论一下。这很有趣。这是一个有趣的论点。但它们都是分支，不是吗？在某种程度上，你可以说马克思主义目前在美国比在中国更有影响力。讨论一下。这很有趣。这是一个有趣的论点。
But they're both offshoots, aren't they, from the sort of the main trunk of communism, which we associate with Marxism. So there had been ideas about a communist society before. So Thomas More in his book Utopia at the beginning of the turn of the 16th century has this vision of a society where people share property in an idealised sort of post-feudal world and the diggers in the English Civil War. But, I mean, these are communist of a kind. They're kind of proto-Marxist ideas, you could argue, couldn't you? Can I? Do you want to bring in your book?
但它们都是分支，不是吗？源自我们与马克思主义联系在一起的共产主义主干。所以在此之前就已经有了关于共产主义社会的想法。托马斯·莫尔在16世纪初的著作《乌托邦》中，就有一种在理想化的后封建世界中人们共享财产的社会愿景，还有英国革命时期的“掘地派”。但是，我的意思是，这些都是某种意义上的共产主义。你可以说它们是某种原始马克思主义思想，不是吗？我可以吗？你想引入你的书吗？
Do you want to do your thing? I mean, everybody's waiting for this. I'm not going to mention my book, but I would say that the prototype of a communist society is the early church. I'm giving you a hard time, Tom, for no very good reason, because I actually find you very convincing on this. I genuinely think you're onto something, so go for it.
你想做你的事吗？我的意思是，每个人都在等这个。我不会提我的书，但我会说共产主义社会的原型是早期教会。我没理由地为难你，汤姆，因为我实际上发现你在这一点上非常有说服力。我真心认为你发现了什么，所以继续吧。
So I think the prototype is the description of the early church in the Acts of the Apostles, where it says that the apostles selling their possessions and goods gave to anyone as he had need. And there's an obvious echo there of Marx's famous dictum from each according to his ability to each according to his needs. And essentially that posed a kind of challenge to Christians, which is, is this a kind of realisable ideal? And it's hard to overemphasise the degree to which in the Roman world, the rich and the powerful assume themselves to be morally superior to those who are poor. And Christianity represents a really profound challenge to that assumption. And in the fifth century, you start to get the notion of a kind of class war that is motivated by Christian doctrine.
所以我认为原型是《使徒行传》中对早期教会的描述，它说使徒们变卖了财产和货物，照各人所需的分给各人。这显然与马克思的名言“各尽所能，各取所需”有呼应。本质上，这给基督徒带来了一种挑战，即这是一种可实现的理想吗？在罗马世界，很难过分强调富人和权贵认为自己在道德上优于穷人的程度。而基督教对这种假设提出了非常深刻的挑战。在五世纪，你开始有了由基督教教义驱动的阶级斗争的概念。
And there's actually a British thinker called Pelagius who argues that humans can redeem themselves from sin through their own efforts. And this manifests itself in a kind of particularly radical Pelagian thought with the idea that the whole of history is an expression basically of the war of the rich on the poor. And that therefore, if you get rid of the rich, then you will have paradise on earth. Yeah. And this gets opposed by particularly Augustine, the great father of the church, who says that humanity has fallen. We can't possibly realise heaven on earth. And so the best that can be hoped for is that the rich will continue to give to the poor. And I think that in essence, I mean, you could say that there you have communism against social democracy set up in the fifth century Roman Empire. It's basically Karl Marx and the Cadbury's family, the sort of philanthropists of
实际上有一位名叫伯拉纠的英国思想家，他认为人类可以通过自己的努力从罪恶中救赎自己。这表现为一种特别激进的伯拉纠思想，认为整个历史基本上是富人对穷人战争的表现。因此，如果你除掉了富人，那么你就会在地球上拥有天堂。是的。这遭到了奥古斯丁的反对，他是教会的伟大教父，他说人类已经堕落了。我们不可能在地球上实现天堂。所以最好的希望是富人继续给予穷人。我认为本质上，我的意思是，你可以说在五世纪的罗马帝国，你有了共产主义对抗社会民主主义。这基本上是卡尔·马克思和吉百利家族，那种慈善家，
St Augustine is a chocolate magnate. Essentially. And Augustine's influence is obviously, he's the huge influence on the church. Pelagius gets branded a heretic. And so over the course of the church's history, there's an extreme anxiety about any suggestion that Christian teaching, particularly in the Gospels, you know, woe to the rich, the last will be first and the first will be last, that these sayings of Christ should be put into social practice. But you do start by the, I mean, essentially the Reformation at its radical fringes is an attempt to put that into practice. Although, of course, you have Calvinists who think if you're rich
圣奥古斯丁是一位巧克力大亨。本质上是这样。奥古斯丁的影响显然是巨大的，他是教会的巨大影响。伯拉纠被贴上了异端的标签。因此，在教会的历史进程中，对于任何暗示基督教教义，特别是福音书中的“富人有祸了”、“在后的将要在前，在前的将要在后”，这些基督的教言应该付诸社会实践的建议，都存在极度的焦虑。但你确实开始，我的意思是，本质上宗教改革在其激进边缘是试图将其付诸实践。当然，你有加尔文主义者认为如果你富有
and successful, that shows that God is smiling on you and that actually being a wealthy merchant or something is a sign of God's favour, right? Absolutely. But on the very, very radical fringes, so even before the Reformation with the Hussite rebellion, you have this amazing communist. communist, I think it's the first attempt to realise a communist society in European history at a place called Tabor, which is named after a mountain in the New Testament. And knights and beggars all join up and start digging this huge, great city. And they're doing it against the backdrop that God is going to judge the world and that paradise will be established on the earth i mean and you can see that that idea of trying to to to build a kind of a universal equality um and that the new jerusalem will be built on earth you know you can see that that's that's kind of waiting then you've got
且成功，那表明上帝在对你微笑，实际上成为一个富有的商人什么的，是上帝恩宠的标志，对吧？绝对是。但在非常、非常激进的边缘，甚至在宗教改革之前的胡斯战争中，你就有这个惊人的共产主义。共产主义，我认为这是欧洲历史上第一次尝试实现共产主义社会，在一个叫塔博尔的地方，它是以新约中的一座山命名的。骑士和乞丐都加入了，开始挖掘这座巨大的城市。他们这样做是在上帝将要审判世界、天堂将在地球上建立的背景下。我的意思是，你可以看到那种试图建立一种普遍平等的想法，以及新耶路撒冷将在地球上建立，你知道，你可以看到那是在等待，然后你有
um about the anabaptists in munster who try to do the same you've got the the diggers in the the english revolution and all these figures are influential on marx so the diggers are now in a what's now what's now a gated community ironically isn't it in way sort of stockbroker that's right stockbroker belt yes um so let's fast forward a bit to the 19th century and the emergence of what people now think of as as communism and now i would argue that that's and and a lot of sort of Karkin communists get very offended if you, and very cross if you say this, but I would say it's so obviously a kind of political religion that it's barely worth arguing about. I mean, it even later on has icons and banners and sacred texts and prophets and all the
嗯，关于明斯特的再洗礼派，他们试图做同样的事情，你有英国革命中的掘地派，所有这些人物对马克思都有影响。所以掘地派现在在什么地方，讽刺的是，在一个封闭式社区里，不是吗？某种股票经纪人，没错，股票经纪人地带，是的。所以让我们快进到19世纪，以及人们现在认为的共产主义的出现。现在我会争辩说，而且很多马克思主义者如果你这么说会感到非常被冒犯，非常生气，但我会说这显然是一种政治宗教，几乎不值得争论。我的意思是，它甚至在后来还有偶像、横幅、神圣文本和先知以及所有
rest of it. But the interesting thing about Marx is that Marx is not from a, I mean, he's from a converted Christian background, but he's actually Jewish heritage, isn't it? But the interesting thing about Marx is that Marx is not from a, I mean, he's from a converted Christian background, but he's actually Jewish heritage, isn't it? But do you think Marxism is basic? I mean, obviously you do because you think everything is Christian, but you're kind of, why don't you-
其余的东西。但关于马克思有趣的一点是，马克思不是来自一个，我的意思是，他来自一个皈依基督教的背景，但他实际上是犹太血统，不是吗？但关于马克思有趣的一点是，马克思不是来自一个，我的意思是，他来自一个皈依基督教的背景，但他实际上是犹太血统，不是吗？但你认为马克思主义是基本的吗？我的意思是，显然你认为是因为你认为一切都是基督教的，但你有点，为什么你不——
We agreed that fascism wasn't. Any remaining sceptical listeners that Marxism is basically religious? Well, I think that, you know, the famous phrase that you read out at the top of the show, a spectre is haunting Europe. The powers of old Europe have entered into holy lands to exercise this spectre. I mean, on the most basic level, Marx has, I mean, he's kind of like a Gothic writer. He's haunted by vampires and werewolves.
我们同意法西斯主义不是。还有任何怀疑马克思主义基本上是宗教的听众吗？嗯，我认为，你知道，你在节目开头读到的那句名言，“一个幽灵在欧洲徘徊。旧欧洲的势力已进入神圣的土地来驱逐这个幽灵。”我的意思是，在最基本的层面上，马克思有，我的意思是，他有点像哥特式作家。他被吸血鬼和狼人所困扰。
And the language of Das Kapital is kind of shot through with the idea that there are supernatural entities. Bloodsuckers and parasites and all that sort of stuff. Yes. But I think on the broader level, Marx takes for granted that the oppression of the poor by the rich and the powerful is wrong. But he doesn't want to say that this is a metaphysical position, because that would immediately kind of lead him wandering into theological dimensions, into the dimension of kind of Christian thought. So he claims that it's all entirely scientific.
《资本论》的语言中贯穿着存在超自然实体的想法。吸血鬼、寄生虫等等。是的。但我认为在更广泛的层面上，马克思认为富人和权贵对穷人的压迫是错误的。但他不想说这是一种形而上学的立场，因为那会立即让他陷入神学维度，陷入基督教思想的维度。所以他声称这一切完全是科学的。
Well, that's the key word, isn't it? The scientific nature of- And materialist, a historicist. So he sits in the British Library, number crunching the facts and lots of graphs, lots of tables, supposedly proving the inevitable fact that all of history is a class warfare and that it is predestined that the wealthy will be overthrown, that a classless paradise will be established.
嗯，那是关键词，不是吗？科学的本质——还有唯物主义，历史主义。所以他坐在大英图书馆里，用数字处理事实，有很多图表，有很多表格，据称证明了所有历史都是阶级斗争的必然事实，并且富人被推翻、无阶级天堂被建立是命中注定的。
And it seems to me that essentially the whole pretense of Marxism to be scientific is a kind of oedipal attempt to deny its christian heritage i think wow that's a big and indeed it's jewish heritage because it fascinatingly one of marx's ancestors was rabbi love who was um a famous rabbi in uh in 16th century prague um who um according to legend fashioned the golem, which was a kind of monstrous automaton, a kind of proto-Frankenstein monster, which is, in a way, a kind of sensational prefiguring of the relationship of the bourgeoisie to the proletariat.
在我看来，马克思主义假装科学的整个过程本质上是一种俄狄浦斯式的尝试，试图否认其基督教遗产。我想，哇，这是一个巨大的，确实是它的犹太遗产，因为令人着迷的是，马克思的一位祖先是拉比洛夫，他是16世纪布拉格的一位著名拉比，根据传说，他塑造了魔像，那是一种怪物般的自动机，一种原始的弗兰肯斯坦怪物，这在某种程度上是对资产阶级与无产阶级关系的耸人听闻的预演。
So there's all kinds of strange stuff swirling around there. And I think the idea that it's scientific is one for the bursary. I mean, what do you think? Well, I mean, I think it's scientific. I think it's scientific in the sense that so many theories and ideas developed in the 19th century were thought to be scientific because it was an age obsessed with science. So it's the age of Darwinism and it's the age of, you know, new technology and the railways and all the rest of it.
所以那里有各种奇怪的东西在盘旋。我认为它是科学的想法是给资产阶级看的。我的意思是，你怎么看？嗯，我的意思是，我认为它是科学的。我认为它是科学的，因为19世纪发展的许多理论和思想都被认为是科学的，因为那是一个痴迷于科学的时代。所以这是达尔文主义的时代，也是你知道，新技术、铁路等等的时代。
So any new theory, almost by definition, is going to be sort of grounded in scientific language and whatnot. And science in this case, it stands in for, I mean, Marxists often talk about being on the right side of history. So this idea of the inevitable progress of history, and it's a scientific law. I mean, science sort of stands in for God, doesn't it in this i think in this um formula so walter benjamin the great german sort of 20th century philosopher he compared marxism's kind of historical materialism as they called it he compared it with the another automaton the turk which was this sort of supposed robot um there was actually a bit of a con um uh created before it was sort of created now i don't know was it the 18th and early 19th century or something and he sort of said you know what's
所以任何新理论，几乎根据定义，都将以科学语言为基础等等。在这种情况下，科学代表了，我的意思是，马克思主义者经常谈论站在历史正确的一边。所以这种历史必然进步的想法，它是一种科学规律。我的意思是，科学在某种程度上代替了上帝，不是吗？在这个公式中。所以我认为瓦尔特·本雅明，那位伟大的德国20世纪哲学家，他将马克思主义的历史唯物主义（他们称之为）与另一个自动机“土耳其人”进行了比较，那是一种所谓的机器人，实际上是一个骗局，在它被创造之前，我不知道，是18世纪还是19世纪初什么的，他有点说，你知道，什么
hiding under the the pretense of all the machinery is actually theology and is this sort of you know that's the that's marxism's dirty little secret that is basically theology posing as a science and i've always sort of thought that. I mean, I can remember when I was at university meeting people who sort of said, you know, at the age of 20 with all their years of experience of the world, they would sort of say, oh, well, I'm a Marxist. And I'd often say, well, how do you know? How have you decided?
隐藏在所有机器的伪装下，实际上是神学，这就是马克思主义不可告人的小秘密，它基本上是伪装成科学的神学，我一直这么认为。我的意思是，我记得我在大学时遇到过一些人，他们说，在20岁时，凭借他们所有的世界经验，他们会说，哦，好吧，我是马克思主义者。我经常会说，你怎么知道？你是怎么决定的？
How at this sort of age where we basically know nothing and we're still reading lots of stuff, how do you know that this is the blueprint that explains the world? And of course, that was a stupid question, because I thought it was a political position, but it wasn't. It was a religious position. It's a statement of religious identity, I think, rather than a sort of... I mean, that's obviously not always the case.
在这个我们基本上什么都不知道、还在读很多东西的年纪，你怎么知道这就是解释世界的蓝图？当然，那是一个愚蠢的问题，因为我以为这是一个政治立场，但它不是。这是一个宗教立场。我认为这是一种宗教身份的声明，而不是一种……我的意思是，这显然并不总是这样。
There are people who are more sceptical Marxists. But it's not necessarily always... When people say they're a Marxist, it's not often... It's not always a sort of say they're a Marxist it's not often it's not always a sort of cognitively carefully developed position often it's inherited so I don't know if you've read David Aronovich's book about growing up in a Marxist sort of milieu I mean Marxists in Britain in the post-war years where Marxism where communism was a tiny thing they had their own dentists they had their own circlesists. They had their own circles of friends. They had their own newspaper.
有一些更怀疑的马克思主义者。但这并不一定总是……当人们说他们是马克思主义者时，这并不经常……这并不总是一种认知上仔细发展的立场，通常它是继承来的。所以我不知道你是否读过大卫·阿罗诺维奇关于在马克思主义环境中长大的书。我的意思是，战后英国的马克思主义者，共产主义是一个微小的东西，他们有自己的牙医，他们有自己的圈子。他们有自己的朋友圈。他们有自己的报纸。
They had their entire own view of the world. It was a closed system, not unlike a religious cult. And in many ways, I think that's what it is. Well, Gramsci was a great admirer of the Catholic Church. And it's interesting that across, particularly Latin America, but also in Catholic countries in Europe, really the battle between Roman Catholicism and communism is often a war between siblings.
他们有自己完整的世界观。这是一个封闭的系统，与宗教邪教没什么不同。在很多方面，我认为这就是它。嗯，葛兰西是天主教会的崇拜者。有趣的是，在整个拉丁美洲，以及欧洲的天主教国家，罗马天主教和共产主义之间的斗争通常是兄弟之间的战争。
And they're both closed systems. But once you buy into it, then everything makes sense. And I think also the other obvious parallel with Christianity is the way in which people get branded heretics and the way in which dogma and doctrine has to be adapted to fit changing circumstance. So Marx's philosophy is clearly bred of the very distinctive circumstances of the mid-19th century. So the revolutions that are going on in 1848 in continental Europe, which end up leading to his exile to Britain,
它们都是封闭的系统。但一旦你接受了它，那么一切就都说得通了。而且我认为与基督教的另一个明显相似之处是人们被贴上异端标签的方式，以及教条和教义必须适应不断变化的环境的方式。所以马克思的哲学显然是19世纪中期非常独特的环境的产物。所以1848年欧洲大陆发生的革命，最终导致他流亡英国，
where he and Engels, who is basically kind of running factories in Manchester and going fox hunting on the weekend and things. So he has a kind of eye view of the way in which the industrial revolution is impacting towns like Manchester, cities like Manchester, and inflicting appalling suffering. And Marx says, prophets have to have beards. He has a big beard.
在那里，他和恩格斯，恩格斯基本上是在曼彻斯特经营工厂，周末去猎狐等等。所以他有一种观察工业革命如何影响曼彻斯特这样的城镇、曼彻斯特这样的城市，并造成可怕痛苦的视角。马克思说，先知必须有胡子。他有一把大胡子。
And there you go. No further proof needed. But also, it's fascinating. I mean, I think also that one of the things that you get from both marx and engels oddly is almost no one writes more and with a greater sense of awe about the achievements of the bourgeoisie than marx i mean he you know he he the way in which he describes the achievements of bourgeois civilization, its restlessness, its kind of global reach, its potency, it's a stupefying portrayal of the achievements of Victorian Britain. And there is also a kind of weird sense in which, if you look at, you know, it's not just Engels with his fox hunting.
就是这样。不需要进一步证明。但这也很有趣。我的意思是，我也认为马克思和恩格斯奇怪地带给你的事情之一是，几乎没有人比马克思写得更多、更敬畏资产阶级的成就。我的意思是，他描述资产阶级文明成就的方式，它的不安，它的全球影响力，它的效力，这是对维多利亚时代英国成就的惊人描绘。而且还有一种奇怪的感觉，如果你看，你知道，不仅仅是恩格斯和他的猎狐。
Marx is kind of, you know, I mean, he's going on seaside holidays, isn't he? I think he's... The Isle of Wight. He's a great fan of the Isle of Wight, I think. Yes. That was it. Because he went to Ventnor, didn't he? For the last fortnight of his life and last holiday.
马克思有点，我的意思是，他去海边度假，不是吗？我想他是……怀特岛。我想他是怀特岛的忠实粉丝。是的。就是那样。因为他去了文特诺，不是吗？在他生命的最后两周和最后一次假期。
And it rained every day. And it's come very puterish. It's like a family holiday in the 1950s. Yes. Yes. So you've got the specifics of Marx's circumstances and Engels. And then, of course, you've got the specifics of marx's circumstances and angles and then of course you've got the very different circumstances of um revolutionaries like lenin who come from a very very different world that's what i wanted to move to because of course the great irony with marxism
而且每天都在下雨。这变得非常像普特尼。这就像1950年代的家庭度假。是的。是的。所以你有马克思和恩格斯环境的具体情况。然后，当然，你有马克思和恩格斯环境的具体情况，然后当然你有像列宁这样的革命者非常非常不同的环境，那是我想要转向的地方，因为当然，马克思主义的巨大讽刺
and with communism is that marx thought exactly that all you're saying about him and the achievements of the bourgeoisie he one reason he likes the achievements of the bourgeoisie is he awed by them is because they have the seeds of their own destruction in One reason he likes the achievements of the bourgeoisie or is he awed by them is because they have the seeds of their own destruction in them. So he thinks the more capitalism develops, the more sort of magnificent it is, the more quickly it will crumble. It's the grave digger.
和共产主义的讽刺在于，马克思认为，关于他和资产阶级的成就，你所说的一切，他喜欢资产阶级成就的一个原因是他对它们感到敬畏，是因为它们有自身毁灭的种子。所以他认为资本主义发展得越多，它就越宏伟，它崩溃得就越快。它是掘墓人。
Again, that gothic quality. Yeah, it is a very gothic expression, isn't it? They're sort of digging their own graves. So he thinks the revolution is going to happen in somewhere like Britain or Germany, the most advanced industrial civilizations. And actually, it happens in Russia, which is the one place that he had thought would be leading the counter-revolution. He'd sort of seen all this counter-revolutionary potential in Russia. So Russia does have two industrial cities,
又是那种哥特式的品质。是的，这是一种非常哥特式的表达，不是吗？他们有点在挖自己的坟墓。所以他认为革命会发生在像英国或德国这样最先进的工业文明中。但实际上，它发生在俄罗斯，他曾认为那里会领导反革命。他曾看到俄罗斯所有这种反革命的潜力。所以俄罗斯确实有两个工业城市，
St. Petersburg and Moscow. But otherwise, it's a huge sort of agrarian giant full of peasants. It's exactly the wrong place in many words, in many ways. It's the wrong place in many ways for communism to take root. And the key figure here is Lenin because Lenin is the person who says, well, actually what you need, you know, it's not just,
圣彼得堡和莫斯科。但除此之外，它是一个巨大的农业巨人，到处都是农民。在很多方面，这完全是错误的地方。在很多方面，这是共产主义扎根的错误地方。这里的关键人物是列宁，因为列宁是那个说，嗯，实际上你需要的是，你知道，不仅仅是，
you don't just need the course of history. What you need is a revolutionary vanguard, a vanguard party that will take the levers of power, stage a coup, grab power, and then push this through whether people, basically whether people like it or not, because it's acting in the course of history. And then, and I think right at the beginning of the, I mean, right from the outset, when Marxism is put into practice, you have basically violence and dictatorship, and you couldn't have it otherwise.
你不仅仅需要历史的进程。你需要的是一个革命先锋队，一个将掌握权力杠杆、发动政变、夺取权力，然后无论人们喜欢与否都强行推行这一点的先锋党，因为它是按照历史进程行事的。然后，我认为就在开始时，我的意思是，从一开始，当马克思主义付诸实践时，你基本上就有暴力和独裁，你不可能有其他方式。
I think also you have the offer of elitism. So the genius of Marxist Leninism is that it offers you, I mean, basically, so the Marxism will appeal to people who are very concerned with social justice, who want equality across the world, who want justice. What Lenin does is to fuse that with the sense that you need a controlling elite um and on the theme of of communists in london um i i did a brilliant radio piece once about this um this room above above what's now a curry shop in white chapel um where i think for about kind of before you know there's a communist conference going on. You had Lenin, Stalin, Trotsky, Rosa Luxemburg,
我认为你还有精英主义的提议。所以马克思列宁主义的天才在于它提供给你，我的意思是，基本上，所以马克思主义会吸引那些非常关心社会正义、想要世界平等、想要正义的人。列宁所做的是将其与你需要一个控制精英的感觉融合在一起。关于伦敦共产主义者的话题，我曾经做过一篇关于这个的精彩广播片段，这个房间在白教堂现在的一家咖喱店上面，我想在大约，你知道，在共产主义会议召开之前。你有列宁、斯大林、托洛茨基、罗莎·卢森堡、
Gorky, Zinoviev, all kind of staying in this, this one bed sit. I always thought it would make an amazing sitcom. Yeah. Yeah. Sitcom.
高尔基、季诺维也夫，都住在这个单间公寓里。我一直认为这会是一部很棒的情景喜剧。是的。是的。情景喜剧。
Very good. Oh, Stalin. And so I think, and I think that they, that the, the brilliant irony of that is, is that that was where the Bolsheviks, i.e. the majoritarians, the people in the majority, were staying. And I think the Mensheviks were, you know, the people in the minority must have been staying in an even smaller room somewhere.
非常好。哦，斯大林。所以我认为，我认为他们，那个辉煌的讽刺是，那是布尔什维克，即多数派，占多数的人住的地方。我认为孟什维克，你知道，少数派的人一定住在某个更小的房间里。
Well, I think, I mean, it's interesting you mentioned Stalin because Stalin kind of hangs over every discussion of communism because you know Stalin murdered millions upon millions of people and and the question with someone like Stalin and what I find so fascinating is Stalin an aberration which Marxists will now often claim oh Stalin was somehow some imposter he was a monster who'd somehow got his hands on the experiments and all got out of control or for example there's the alternative view which is I don't know if you read these monstrously big books by stephen kotkin this american scholar who's working his way through stalin's life and he says no everyone's got stalin wrong stalin wasn't a madman stalin wasn't even necessarily a
嗯，我认为，我的意思是，你提到斯大林很有趣，因为斯大林笼罩着每一次关于共产主义的讨论，因为你知道斯大林谋杀了数以百万计的人，而像斯大林这样的人的问题，我发现最迷人的是，斯大林是一个畸变吗？马克思主义者现在经常声称，哦，斯大林不知何故是一个冒名顶替者，他是一个怪物，不知何故掌握了实验，一切都失控了。或者，例如，有另一种观点，我不知道你是否读过斯蒂芬·科特金写的那些巨大的书，这位美国学者正在研究斯大林的生平，他说不，每个人都误解了斯大林，斯大林不是一个疯子，斯大林甚至不一定是
sadist or you know any of these things that we imagine he's not sort of traumatized by his childhood he's none of those things stalin is actually a very good Marxist. He spent all his life immersed in Marxist ideas. He's written tons of incredibly tedious articles about aspects of Marxism in Bolshevik journals. And actually, the reason that he kills all these people is because he thinks that's the way to achieve the paradise, that he's actually a good Marxist. And that's the thing that when he makes his decisions, that's what always drives him on. And that actually the violence is inherent and the killing is inherent because that's the only way you're going to achieve this good society. Well, I think that when you look at Stalin or Mao or indeed Hitler, you have to bear in mind
一个虐待狂，或者你知道我们想象的任何这些事情，他没有被他的童年所创伤，他都不是这些。斯大林实际上是一个非常好的马克思主义者。他一生都沉浸在马克思主义思想中。他在布尔什维克期刊上写了大量关于马克思主义各个方面的极其乏味的文章。实际上，他杀害所有这些人是因为他认为这是实现天堂的方法，他实际上是一个好的马克思主义者。这就是当他做出决定时，总是驱使他的东西。实际上，暴力是内在的，杀戮是内在的，因为那是你实现这个美好社会的唯一途径。嗯，我认为当你看着斯大林或毛泽东，或者确实是希特勒时，你必须记住
that by their lights, what they're doing, they're doing for the best. And the idea of killing millions in the cause of bringing about some ideal earthly situation is so monstrous to most of us that it takes such a gear shift that I think it's difficult to do that. But I agree. I think that Stalinism develops logically out of Leninism, which in turn is a logical attempt to adapt Marx's theory to, as you said, the kind of unexpected fact that the revolution's happened in Russia and not in Britain or Germany. But I also think, Tom, that by its nature, it has to be violent because there's always a confiscatory element in communism. You know, some people have to be brought down. And those people are never going to say, sure, have all my furniture, you know, have my second home, please take it.
根据他们的观点，他们所做的事情，他们是为了最好的结果。为了实现某种理想的世俗状况而杀害数百万人，这对我们大多数人来说是如此可怕，以至于它需要一个档位转换，我认为这很难做到。但我同意。我认为斯大林主义在逻辑上是从列宁主义发展而来的，而列宁主义反过来又是将马克思理论适应你所说的，革命发生在俄罗斯而不是英国或德国这种意想不到的事实的逻辑尝试。但我还认为，汤姆，就其本质而言，它必须是暴力的，因为共产主义中总有一种没收的成分。你知道，有些人必须被拉下来。而这些人永远不会说，当然，拿走我所有的家具，你知道，拿走我的第二套房子，请拿走它。
You know, there's always going to be, violence is inherent in it. And violence is in the language. I mean, Lenin's language was extraordinarily violent. And Lenin, of course, famously said, you know, I used to like music and listening to nice, you know, songs and fluffy animals and nice books and stuff. But now I can't do that. I have to be harder than hard. Those things will weaken me for when I become dictator, you know, when I'll have to kill people. And he's
你知道，总会有，暴力是内在的。而且暴力在语言中。我的意思是，列宁的语言是非常暴力的。当然，列宁著名地说，你知道，我曾经喜欢音乐和听好听的歌曲，毛茸茸的动物和好书之类的东西。但现在我不能那样做了。我必须比硬更硬。那些事情会削弱我，当我成为独裁者时，你知道，当我不得不杀人时。他是
as good as his word. And I think to that, the idea of there being a separation between this sort of cuddly Marxism that Lenin supposedly incarnates, and then the sort of, you know, the mass graves Marxism of Stalin, I think is a false image. Anyway, we need to take a break, Tom. Sorry. We need to take a break. The listeners are very keen to go and overthrow social conditions and collectivise agriculture.
言出必行。我认为，列宁据称体现的那种可爱的马克思主义与斯大林的万人坑马克思主义之间存在分离的想法，我认为是一个错误的形象。无论如何，我们需要休息一下，汤姆。抱歉。我们需要休息一下。听众们非常渴望去推翻社会条件并集体化农业。
So I think we should let them do it and we'll have a cup of tea and then you can say what you wanted to say after the break. How about that? They're going to go and listen to adverts aren't they well marx would approve i'm sure all right we'll see you after you've um you've indulged some capitalist impulses see in a minute i'm marina hyde and i'm richard osman and together we host the rest is entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our q a we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club if you want ad-free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to the rest of the entertainment.com that's
所以我认为我们应该让他们去做，我们会喝杯茶，然后你可以在休息后说你想说的话。那样怎么样？他们会去听广告，不是吗？嗯，马克思会赞成的，我相信。好的，在你沉迷于一些资本主义冲动之后，我们再见。一会儿见。我是玛丽娜·海德，我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们一起主持《历史的余味》。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点演艺圈八卦的固定节目，在我们的问答环节，我们揭开娱乐的面纱，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部，如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和抢先获得现场门票，请前往 therestistheentertainment.com，那是
the rest is history on thursday we're offering that natural companion piece to today's discussion on communism we're talking elizabeth the first with the historian tracy boorman and here's an early warning for your diaries on the evening of wednesday the 21st of april we are going to do something very exciting. We're going to do our first live episode of the podcast, live on the internet, and it's going to be all about assassinations. Abraham Lincoln, John F. Kennedy, Indira
《历史的余味》。周四，我们将提供今天关于共产主义讨论的自然配套作品。我们将与历史学家特蕾西·博曼谈论伊丽莎白一世。这里有一个给你们日记的早期警告，4月21日星期三晚上，我们将做一些非常令人兴奋的事情。我们将做我们的第一期播客直播，在互联网上直播，它将全部关于暗杀。亚伯拉罕·林肯、约翰·F·肯尼迪、英迪拉·
Gandhi, Tom will no doubt be talking about Julius Caesar. Not to anticipate, Tom. No, yeah, Caligula, of course, very good. Loads of Romans. So we'll post a link on Twitter that week. Everybody is welcome, so you can join the show and we'll be answering the questions live. You can throw
甘地，汤姆无疑会谈论朱利叶斯·凯撒。不要预料，汤姆。不，是的，卡里古拉，当然，非常好。很多罗马人。所以我们会在那一周在推特上发布一个链接。欢迎大家加入，这样你就可以加入节目，我们将现场回答问题。你可以扔
your abuse at us then and there's nowhere for us to hide. It will be a lot of fun for everybody. Now, Tom, I cut you off and you wanted to say something unbelievably interesting about communism. Well, yeah, unbelievably interesting, but I'm going to combine it with the first of the many, many questions we've had.
你的辱骂给我们，就在那时，我们无处可藏。这对每个人来说都会很有趣。现在，汤姆，我打断了你，你想说一些关于共产主义的令人难以置信的有趣的事情。嗯，是的，令人难以置信的有趣，但我将把它与我们收到的许多许多问题中的第一个结合起来。
And this is from Duncan Hibbard, where he says, is communism inherently totalitarian? I'm wondering about Lenin and Stalin. Isn't Stalinism essentially economically based? So it's about trying to reconfigure the economy. And once you do that, then inevitably, in a sense, you have to kind of seize control of every possible lever. There is no space left for anyone to do anything that the government isn't controlling. And that there might be, I don't know, i mean i mean grampski would be maybe an alternative form of communism that puts an emphasis on control of culture rather than of
这是来自邓肯·希巴德的，他说，共产主义本质上是极权主义的吗？我在想列宁和斯大林。斯大林主义本质上不是基于经济的吗？所以它是关于试图重构经济。一旦你那样做了，那么不可避免地，在某种意义上，你必须夺取每一个可能的杠杆的控制权。没有空间留给任何人做任何政府没有控制的事情。而且可能存在，我不知道，我的意思是，葛兰西可能是另一种形式的共产主义，它强调对文化的控制，而不是对
the economy okay so i would say it probably is inherently totalitarian because it's not pluralist you know if you're a communist you don't tolerate you know you can't really tolerate challenges um i think and of course lenin's idea of kind of democratic centralism is that basically when the parties agreed, everybody must agree. And you can't have, you can't, you know, Marx and Lenin hated dissent or disagreement. I mean, they spent an enormous amount of time trying to crush any sort of disagreement among their own kind of little group of schools. So I think it probably does have an inherently totalitarian bent. And I think, Tom, going back to what you're saying, Stalin thought that Russia needed rapidly to industrialize
经济的控制。好的，所以我会说它可能本质上是极权主义的，因为它不是多元主义的。你知道，如果你是共产主义者，你不容忍，你知道，你不能真正容忍挑战。我认为，当然，列宁关于民主集中制的想法是，基本上当党同意时，每个人都必须同意。你不能有，你不能，你知道，马克思和列宁讨厌异议或分歧。我的意思是，他们花了大量时间试图粉碎他们自己那一小群学校中的任何分歧。所以我认为它可能确实有一种内在的极权主义倾向。而且我认为，汤姆，回到你所说的，斯大林认为俄罗斯需要迅速工业化
because he completely imbibed the kind of Marxist idea about the course of history, that you'd become an industrial country and then you'd become a communist one. So he pushes that through, you know, and he demands total control, and it's mainly the collectivisation of agriculture. I mean, that's what kills a lot of people at the turn of the 1930s.
因为他完全吸收了关于历史进程的那种马克思主义思想，即你会成为一个工业国家，然后你会成为一个共产主义国家。所以他强行推行这一点，你知道，他要求完全控制，这主要是农业的集体化。我的意思是，这就是在1930年代初杀害很多人的原因。
Because there's no other source of revenue. Yeah, because he needs to – exactly. He wants to rapidly, rapidly industrialise. He wants to sell grain abroad. He wants to get people into the factories. He wants to cut out – he hates the idea of, you know, private ownership among the peasants, the kulaks who have built up their own little small holdings.
因为没有其他收入来源。是的，因为他需要——完全正确。他想迅速、迅速地工业化。他想把粮食卖到国外。他想把人们送进工厂。他想切断——他讨厌你知道，农民、那些建立了自己小块土地的富农之间的私有制想法。
He wants to crush them, not because he's a... I mean, his latest biography would say, not because he's a mad monster, this sort of slavering demon, but because he's a Marxist, because he thinks that's what you do to get the good society. But he's a Marxist who has turned his back on a fairly fundamental proposition of Marx. That this is something universal. I mean, he's pushing the idea of socialism in one country.
他想粉碎他们，不是因为他是一个……我的意思是，他最新的传记会说，不是因为他是一个疯狂的怪物，这种流口水的恶魔，而是因为他是一个马克思主义者，因为他认为这就是你为了得到美好社会所做的事情。但他是一个背弃了马克思一个相当基本主张的马克思主义者。这是一个普遍的东西。我的意思是，他正在推行一国社会主义的想法。
He is, you're right. Yes. And so that, I mean, it's that basically that I guess once he's made that decision, once he's hitched his start of that idea, an awful lot then follows from that because immediately people in other countries are cast as enemies and immediately the focus has to be on a kind of, I suppose, a kind of communist nationalism. The list of countries that you,
他是，你是对的。是的。所以那，我的意思是，基本上我猜一旦他做出了那个决定，一旦他把他的星系挂在那个想法上，很多事情就会随之而来，因为其他国家的人立即被视为敌人，焦点必须立即放在一种，我想，一种共产主义民族主义上。你列出的国家，
at the beginning of the programme where you listed as communist, didn't include North Korea. And I guess that, you know, I mean, it's a kind of monarchy isn't it with a yeah dead rather like saint catholic yes yes um a kind of dead body presiding over which shows the kind of weird ways in which communism can evolve but i mean it's it's a lot of the a lot of the kind of most monstrous crimes are where communism fuses with nationalism. So in the Ukraine, for example, Stalin, the famine that Stalin causes there.
在节目开始时你列为共产主义的，不包括朝鲜。我猜，你知道，我的意思是，它是一种君主制，不是吗？有一个，是的，死去的，很像圣天主教，是的，是的，嗯，一种死尸主持着，这显示了共产主义可以演变的奇怪方式，但我的意思是，很多很多最可怕的罪行是共产主义与民族主义融合的地方。例如在乌克兰，斯大林，斯大林在那里造成的饥荒。
I mean, obviously, if that had been in Russia, if it had been just outside Moscow, you're right. I think there might have been a different kind of reaction to it. I mean, our producer was hectoring me. Hectoring is probably a bit harsh, but he was giving me a hard time. He said, you know, if Stalin is just a good Marxist, how does that explain the backlash against Stalin after his death in 1953? You know, Khrushchev makes the secret speech in which he denounces Stalin's crimes. And then there's a sort of slight thawing in the Soviet Union.
我的意思是，显然，如果那是在俄罗斯，如果它只是在莫斯科郊外，你是对的。我想可能会有不同类型的反应。我的意思是，我们的制片人在纠缠我。纠缠可能有点刺耳，但他确实在为难我。他说，你知道，如果斯大林只是一个好的马克思主义者，那怎么解释1953年他死后对斯大林的强烈反对？你知道，赫鲁晓夫发表了秘密演讲，谴责了斯大林的罪行。然后苏联有了一点解冻。
I mean, I think there's no doubt that Stalin became incredibly despotic and that power corrupted, as it were. But I think a lot of those people who are... I mean, there's an interesting question about how Marxists are the leaders of the Soviet Union after the 1950s, or how much are they... I mean, in some ways, they're quite conservative. They're no longer pushing to create the new jerusalem they're defensive they're simply what we have we hold i think and i think yes and they're defensive because because of the role played by the party
我的意思是，我认为毫无疑问斯大林变得极其专制，权力腐败了，正如他们所说。但我认为那些人中有很多……我的意思是，关于1950年代后苏联领导人是马克思主义者，或者他们有多少是……这是一个有趣的问题。我的意思是，在某些方面，他们相当保守。他们不再推动创造新耶路撒冷，他们是防御性的，他们只是我们有什么我们就持有。我认为是的，他们是防御性的，因为党所扮演的角色。
which becomes a kind of elite and then if obviously if you're you know if you're in the party you hold power and if you hold power then you want to keep hold of it. Yeah. So I think the weird thing is these are people who in Red Square every May, they stand there on the balcony, which is on Lenin's tomb, to go back to our St. Cuthbert analogy. They're standing above the sort of mummified body of Lenin. And all these people are parading past with pictures of great icons of Karl Marx. But Marx, if he saw those men, probably wouldn't recognize them as his comrades, because he's always been an outsider, a radical, a journalist tilting against convention,
这变成了一种精英阶层，显然，如果你身处党内，你就掌握权力，而如果你掌握了权力，你就会想要保住它。是的。所以我认为奇怪的是，这些人每年五月都会站在红场的列宁墓顶上，回到我们之前提到的圣卡斯伯特（St. Cuthbert）的比喻，他们站在列宁那具木乃伊的上方。所有这些人都在游行，手里拿着卡尔·马克思的伟大肖像。但如果马克思看到这些人，他可能根本认不出他们是他的同志，因为他一直是个局外人、激进分子、一个对抗传统的记者，
whereas they are the ultimate defenders of convention, Brezhnev and all these sort of identikit gerontocrats in their sort of gray suits i mean these aren't people that marx would sort of i don't think you'd enjoy their company and i guess you can say the same about china where it's marxism leninism with chinese characteristics isn't it yeah um so in china again that that question of now, is it a communist state? I mean, clearly, formally it is. Do the Chinese Communist Party in China, are they communist? Do they believe it? I don't think they are.
而他们却是传统的终极捍卫者，勃列日涅夫和所有这些穿着灰色西装、长相千篇一律的老年官僚，我的意思是，这些人并不是马克思会……我不认为他会喜欢他们的陪伴。我想关于中国也可以这么说，那是具有中国特色的马克思列宁主义，不是吗？是的，嗯，所以在中国，同样的问题是，现在它还是一个共产主义国家吗？我的意思是，从形式上讲显然是。中国的中国共产党，他们是共产主义者吗？他们相信吗？我不认为他们是。
I mean, I think, you know, in the same way that you could possibly – well, it's an interesting one, isn't it, Tom? I mean, were people Christians? You, in the same way that you could possibly – well, it's an interesting one, isn't it, Tom? I mean, were people Christians? You know, were all these medieval monarchs – they believed they were Christians, I suppose. But, you know, when they read about turning the other cheek and all that sort of stuff, it's harder for a rich man isn't it, with the leaders of the Soviet Union or indeed of China, that they think they believe it but they don't live it, maybe is a distinction. I don't know. We should move on to another question.
我的意思是，我认为，你知道，就像你可能——嗯，这很有趣，不是吗，汤姆？我的意思是，人们是基督徒吗？你知道，所有这些中世纪的君主——我想他们相信自己是基督徒。但是，你知道，当他们读到“打你的左脸，连右脸也转过来”之类的教导时，对于一个富人来说这很难，不是吗？苏联或中国的领导人也是如此，他们认为自己相信，但他们并没有践行，这或许是一个区别。我不知道。我们应该讨论下一个问题了。
We should move on to Beatrice Mouse. Beatrice Mouse says, for those who say it hasn't been tried properly, isn't its failure baked in? Properly ends up with economic failure and tyranny? I mean, this is the stuff of a thousand social media arguments. Has it been tried properly or not? Do you think, Tom, it's been tried properly?
我们应该讨论比阿特丽斯·鼠标（Beatrice Mouse）的问题。比阿特丽斯·鼠标说，对于那些说它没有被正确尝试过的人，它的失败难道不是注定的吗？“正确地”尝试最终会导致经济失败和暴政吗？我的意思是，这是成千上万社交媒体争论的话题。它到底有没有被正确尝试过？你认为呢，汤姆，它被正确尝试过吗？
Do you think it's been given a fair crack of the whip? Well, I think to go back to the key perspective of Marx, it's about justice and it's about liberating people to fulfill their potential. And if you think of it in those terms, rather than in the supposed ironclad economic laws that will make it happen, and the whole kind of ideological apparatus that has been built up around it, think that um that that ideal absolutely preserves its its its power and to go back what i was saying at the beginning of the program i think that um you know a lot of of uh a lot of what what is is um agitating uh people in the west at the moment is kind of recognizably bred of that matrix. I think.
你认为它得到过公平的对待吗？嗯，我认为回到马克思的核心观点，它是关于正义的，是关于解放人们以发挥其潜力的。如果你从这些角度去思考，而不是从那些所谓的、注定会实现的钢铁般的经济规律，以及围绕它建立起来的整个意识形态机器去思考，我认为那种理想绝对保留了它的力量。回到我在节目开头所说的，我认为，你知道，目前在西方激怒人们的很多东西，在某种程度上是可以辨认出源自那个体系的。我想是这样。
So you, so you, you, so that's slightly evasive answer. You haven't said whether you think it has or hasn't been tried properly. I think the assumption is because we've had communist States, we think that there is such a thing as, as communism. Yeah.
所以，你，所以你，你，这是一个稍微有点回避的回答。你还没有说你认为它是否被正确尝试过。我认为人们的假设是，因为我们有过共产主义国家，所以我们认为存在“共产主义”这种东西。是的。
But I think that if you think of it again, perhaps again, a bit more like a, like Christianity or something like that, as an ongoing way of living, an approach, an ideal, an attempt to shape your life by certain ideals. Then I think that the idea
但我认为，如果你再次思考它，也许再次，更像是一种基督教之类的东西，作为一种持续的生活方式、一种方法、一种理想、一种试图用某些理想来塑造你生活的方式。那么我认为这个想法
of, I mean, and I know that of course Marx is talking about the fact that they will ultimately be a class of society. So that is baked into his perspective. But it's very telling, I think, that in his writings he barely talks about it. And even Lenin, I mean, he's obsessed with the dictatorship of the proletariat, and you need the dictatorship of the proletariat to usher in what will ultimately be the classless state. It's just that it never arrives. So I guess to the degree
——我的意思是，我知道马克思当然是在谈论最终会出现一个无阶级社会。所以这已经融入了他的视角。但我认为非常能说明问题的是，他在著作中几乎没有谈论过它。甚至列宁，我的意思是，他痴迷于无产阶级专政，你需要无产阶级专政来开启最终的无阶级国家。只是它从未到来。所以我猜，在某种程度上，
that the New Jerusalem will never be built on Earth, the class of society will never arrive. Yeah, failure is inevitable because it's not going to happen because this is a theological myth. But I think that as a way of governing your life, clearly it provides meaning for people across the face of the of the planet and it continues to convulse and agitate the way that um you know certainly british society american society uh european society is is is operating at the moment i think i think that if you think of communism as a uh as a way of living rather than an inevitable end point i i don't think i think that that's would be my take you see what i would say tom is if even if you think of it as a way of living, if you look at all the regimes that proclaim themselves communist,
新耶路撒冷永远不会在地球上建成，无阶级社会也永远不会到来。是的，失败是不可避免的，因为它不会发生，因为这是一个神学神话。但我认为，作为一种指导你生活的方式，它显然为全球的人们提供了意义，并且它继续搅动和激荡着，你知道，当然还有英国社会、美国社会、欧洲社会目前运作的方式。我想，我想如果你把共产主义看作一种生活方式，而不是一个不可避免的终点，我想这就是我的看法。你会说，汤姆，即使你把它看作一种生活方式，如果你看看所有宣称自己是共产主义的政权，
and there were quite a lot. I mean, we're talking about dozens. There are lots of examples of people where they've taught capital, das Kapital in schools, where they've had all the banners, where they've had the pictures of Marx, where, you know,
而且数量相当多。我的意思是，我们谈论的是几十个。有很多例子，人们在学校里教授资本论，他们有所有的横幅，他们有马克思的画像，你知道，
academies have been devoted to this stuff where they, where they really thought they were following it. And in every one there's been, you know, repression violence. Yeah. I mean, that there's a point at which you sort of say,
学院致力于研究这些东西，他们真的认为自己在追随它。而在每一个例子中，都有，你知道，镇压和暴力。是的。我的意思是，在某种程度上你会说，
well, maybe this isn't a coincidence. Maybe this is kind of baked into the, to the, to the, to the project from the very, from the very outset, I think because of its anti-pluralist nature,
嗯，也许这并非巧合。也许这从一开始就融入了这个项目，我认为是因为它反多元主义的本质，
because if you claim to have a monopoly on truth, and if you claim we are carrying out the will of history, as all these regimes did, particularly from 1945 onwards, then you're always going to get into trouble because any form of challenge is illegitimate. Yeah, and I think the idea that there are ironclad economic rules
因为如果你声称拥有真理的垄断权，如果你声称我们正在执行历史的意志，正如所有这些政权所做的那样，特别是在1945年之后，那么你总是会陷入麻烦，因为任何形式的挑战都是非法的。是的，我认为那种存在必须遵循的钢铁般的经济规则的想法，
that have to be followed, even when they don't actually work, is a huge part of the problem. But on the broadest level, I think it is impossible to build Jerusalem on earth. I think Augustine is right. I think that we are fallen, however you want to put it. Humans are not capable of living like that. And it's true of communists, it's true of Christians, it's true of Muslims, wherever you try and build the ideal state without acknowledging
即使它们实际上并不奏效，也是问题的一大部分。但在最广泛的层面上，我认为在地球上建立耶路撒冷是不可能的。我认为奥古斯丁是对的。我认为我们是堕落的，无论你怎么说。人类没有能力那样生活。这对共产主义者来说是真的，对基督徒来说是真的，对穆斯林来说也是真的，无论你在哪里试图建立理想国，而不承认
the fact that humans are humans and things are going to go wrong, you end up with disaster. Have you ever seen this stuff or read this stuff about Boris Yeltsin going to America? So Boris Yeltsin,
人类终究是人类，事情总会出错的事实，你最终都会导致灾难。你见过或读过关于鲍里斯·叶利钦去美国的事情吗？所以鲍里斯·叶利钦，
I think he's the, what is he then? Is he the, he's a big figure, I think, and he's just been kicked out of the Politburo, but he's still big
我想他是，他当时是什么？他是一个大人物，我想，他刚刚被踢出了政治局，但他仍然很有影响力，
in the Russian parliament or he's a big Moscow party boss or, and he's just been kicked out of the Politburo, but he's still big in the Russian parliament, or he's a big Moscow party boss or something. Is he mayor of Moscow? Exactly, mayor of Moscow, I think he is. He goes off to visit NASA near Houston, and on the way he says, I actually want to see what America is really like away from all the handlers. And he stops in a place called Clear Lake,
在俄罗斯议会中，或者他是莫斯科的党魁，或者他刚刚被踢出了政治局，但他仍然在俄罗斯议会中很有影响力，或者他是莫斯科的党魁之类的。他是莫斯科市长吗？没错，我想他是莫斯科市长。他去休斯顿附近的NASA参观，在路上他说，我实际上想看看离开所有随从后，美国到底是什么样子。他在一个叫克利尔湖（Clear Lake）的地方停了下来，
and he goes to a supermarket called Randall's. And there's pictures of him in this supermarket inspecting the freezer cabinets and stuff. And it's just a kind of piddling little supermarket. And he's ashen-faced. He is horrified. And he gets in his car afterwards, and all the people, his aides said, you know, he didn't speak for kind of 40 minutes or something. And he gets in his car afterwards and all the people, his aides said, you know, he didn't speak for kind of
他去了一家叫兰德尔（Randall's）的超市。有他在超市里检查冷冻柜之类的照片。那只是一个微不足道的小超市。他面色苍白。他感到震惊。之后他上了车，所有的人，他的助手说，你知道，他有40分钟左右没说话。之后他上了车，所有的人，他的助手说，你知道，他有40分钟左右
40 minutes or something. And he was so distressed. And he said, how we have failed, you know, the Russian people. It's just abominable that Americans are living like this.
没说话。他非常痛苦。他说，我们是如何辜负了俄罗斯人民的。美国人过着这样的生活，这简直太可恶了。
And, you know, supermarkets in Russia have got a dead dog in them or something. And that's it. And he's just, and it's astounding the extent to which even the kind of elite
而且，你知道，俄罗斯的超市里有死狗之类的东西。就是这样。他只是，而且令人震惊的是，即使是那种精英阶层
were kind of living in a complete fantasy world. And the spectacle of what capitalism was actually really like was just this dreadful shock when Yeltsin realised. Is it Reaganite propaganda that Gorbachev basically realised the game was up when he went to California and flew in a helicopter over LA and looked down at all the swimming pools or something. I don't know. So I think certainly one of Gorbachev's key aides was a man called Alexander Yakovlev. He went to Canada and he became friends with Trudeau. And he was devastated by what he saw in Canada. You know, it was just like to see how ordinary people lived was because, of course, people were told that only the elite lived like this.
也生活在一个完全幻想的世界里。当叶利钦意识到资本主义实际上是什么样子时，那种景象简直是一个可怕的冲击。这是里根式的宣传吗？戈尔巴乔夫基本上是在去加利福尼亚，坐直升机飞过洛杉矶，俯瞰所有的游泳池时意识到游戏结束了。我不知道。所以我认为戈尔巴乔夫的一位关键助手亚历山大·雅科夫列夫（Alexander Yakovlev）肯定去过加拿大，并与特鲁多成为了朋友。他对在加拿大看到的一切感到震惊。你知道，看到普通人是如何生活的，因为当然，人们被告知只有精英才过这样的生活。
That, you know, in Russia, you believed that the kind of Western elite was selling a lie and that everybody was actually really downtrodden and miserable. And to get there, I think for a lot, and the same with Oleg Gordievsky, actually, who we talked about with Ben McIntyre, the defector, he too,
在俄罗斯，你相信西方精英在撒谎，每个人实际上都生活在水深火热之中。而到达那里，我想对很多人来说，还有奥列格·戈尔季耶夫斯基（Oleg Gordievsky），实际上，我们和本·麦金泰尔（Ben McIntyre）谈论过那个叛逃者，他也是，
you know, he was in Copenhagen. And again, he was, you know, standing there thinking we are the baddest. Okay. Okay. But I think,
你知道，他在哥本哈根。同样，他站在那里想，我们才是坏蛋。好吧。好吧。但我认为，
you see, I think that's been reconfigured since the fall of the Berlin wall and the collapse of communism in the Soviet union, because because that that spectacle of wealth of course was precisely what shocked marx and what you've what you get in in capital away from all the graphs and the figures is this sense of kind of molten anger at the way in which um the prosperity of the bourgeoisie depends upon you you know, children starving and people being evicted from their homes. And I think more particularly, people in distant colonies, you know, being worked to death so that the bourgeoisie can have sugar with their
你看，我认为自从柏林墙倒塌和苏联共产主义崩溃以来，这种情况已经被重构了，因为那种财富的景象当然正是震惊马克思的东西，而你在《资本论》中，抛开所有的图表和数字，所得到的是一种对资产阶级繁荣依赖于，你知道，儿童挨饿和人们被赶出家园的方式的熔岩般的愤怒。我认为更具体地说，是远方殖民地的人们，你知道，为了让资产阶级能在茶里加糖而被累死。我认为今天，西方财富的景象对许多人来说以类似的方式运作。我认为这是全球关系理解中的一个巨大动力，即西方财富建立在系统性剥削之上的想法，所以列宁关于帝国主义是资产阶级文明的终极表现的想法，我认为这在当代文化中仍然有余响。
tea. And I think that actually today, the spectacle of Western wealth operates for many people in a similar way. And I think that that's a huge dynamic in the the kind of understanding of global relations the idea that western wealth has been built on systematic exploitation um and so lenin's idea that imperialism is kind of the last you know the ultimate manifestation of bourgeois civilization i think that that still has a an afterlife in contemporary culture it definitely does and it's very popular the problem though that you have if you're going to take that line i think is how do you explain then you know the massive rise in life expectancy
它确实有，而且非常流行。但是，如果你要采取这种路线，你面临的问题是，你如何解释非洲和亚洲等地生活预期和生活水平的巨大提升？
and living standards in places like in africa and in asia so these are well particularly asia but also in africa too i mean the rise in the rise in life expectancy for example um you know these are never have so you know in many ways of course because there are more people there are more poor people than ever but but relatively speaking the human race now lives longer we live longer much more comfortable much more prosperous lives insulated from the fear of early death or disease than any generation before us i I mean, that's punishing environmental costs, as we all know. But the problem is the exploitation of the poor argument. I mean, not everything is based on sweatshops.
所以这些，嗯，特别是亚洲，但也包括非洲，我的意思是，例如生活预期的提升，你知道，这些从来没有……所以你知道，在许多方面，当然因为人口更多，所以穷人比以往任何时候都多，但相对而言，人类现在活得更久，我们活得更久，生活更舒适、更繁荣，免于早逝或疾病的恐惧，比我们之前的任何一代人都好。我的意思是，正如我们所知，这有沉重的环境代价。但问题是“剥削穷人”的论点。我的意思是，并非一切都基于血汗工厂。
Anyway, we need to do some questions, Tom. Yes. If there are any listeners still left, they're probably outraged. Go on, ask a question. Here's one from Chet Archbold, who always comes up with good questions. Was the development of some sort of communist ideology inevitable in Europe? There were some communist-like movements before Marx,
总之，我们需要回答一些问题，汤姆。是的。如果还有听众在听的话，他们可能很愤怒。来吧，问个问题。这是切特·阿奇博尔德（Chet Archbold）提出的，他总是能提出好问题。某种共产主义意识形态在欧洲的发展是不可避免的吗？在马克思之前就有一些类似共产主义的运动，
but if Marx had not lived, would something quite like Marxism have emerged? And that's great, isn't it? Because an awful lot of Marxists, that certain things are inevitable. And that, you know, someone like Marx is just epiphenomenal. He's just a bubble of froth on a heaving ocean.
但如果马克思没有活过，是否会出现类似马克思主义的东西？这很棒，不是吗？因为很多马克思主义者认为某些事情是不可避免的。而且，你知道，像马克思这样的人只是表象。他只是汹涌海洋上的泡沫。
This is a bit like the question I think we've debated before. Would the Beatles have, you know, if John and Paul had never met, would there still have been the Beatles? There would still have been Marxism. Yeah, clearly. Because Marx was building on Saint-Simon and Fourier and Robert Owen. There were loads of thinkers of this kind. Yeah, Proudhon, exactly.
这有点像我们之前讨论过的问题。披头士乐队，你知道，如果约翰和保罗从未见过面，还会不会有披头士乐队？仍然会有马克思主义。是的，显然。因为马克思是建立在圣西门、傅立叶和罗伯特·欧文的基础上的。有很多这样的思想家。是的，蒲鲁东，没错。
So there was Bakunin and there were other people who of this kind. Yeah, Proudhon, exactly. So there was Bakunin and there were other people who could have been sort of, maybe would have loomed larger than Marx. I mean, Marx was in many ways a genius. I don't think there can be any doubt of that. A man of enormous intellectual capability, which is why he became such a big figure. And he's a great self-promoter
所以有巴枯宁，还有其他人，也许他们会比马克思显得更重要。我的意思是，马克思在许多方面是个天才。我认为这一点毫无疑问。一个拥有巨大智力能力的人，这就是为什么他成为了一个大人物。他是一个伟大的自我推销者，
and a great propagandist as well. And the Communist Manifesto is a great read. And he's a great self-promoter and a great propagandist as well. And the communist manifesto is a great read, but there would have been, don't you think there would have been some form of. Yeah, I do. I think, I think,
也是一个伟大的宣传家。《共产党宣言》是一本伟大的读物。他是一个伟大的自我推销者，也是一个伟大的宣传家，但肯定会有，你不觉得会有某种形式的……是的，我确实这么认为。我认为，
however, and again, not to sound like go on my King Charles's head. I think that the hostility to religion might have been less because there were many communist thinkers who were very keen on all that kind of cloudy, fluffy, heavenly stuff as to dismiss it. So I think that's maybe the key thing that Mark's brought to the party.
然而，再次声明，不是为了听起来像……继续说我的查尔斯国王的头。我认为对宗教的敌意可能会少一些，因为有许多共产主义思想家非常热衷于所有那些模糊、蓬松、天堂般的东西，而不是将其斥为无稽之谈。所以我认为这可能是马克思带给这个派别的关键点。
The producer is gagging for us to do Rick Hunter's question. God knows why. But, I mean, maybe he is Rick Hunter, or maybe Rick Hunter has something on him. So Rick Hunter, no offence, Rick. Rick Hunter says, he's about the Mensheviks, if the Mensheviks had launched the Russianussian revolution instead of the bolsheviks how would things have played out was that ever a real possibility i would say no it probably wasn't a
制片人急切地想让我们回答里克·亨特（Rick Hunter）的问题。天知道为什么。但是，我的意思是，也许他就是里克·亨特，或者里克·亨特抓住了他的什么把柄。所以里克·亨特，无意冒犯，里克。里克·亨特说，他是关于孟什维克的，如果孟什维克发动了俄国革命而不是布尔什维克，事情会如何发展？那曾经是一个真正的可能性吗？我会说不，那可能不是一个
real well it would have been a completely different revolution tom what do you think well i think that um i mean the the difference between bolsheviks and mensheviks is essentially how brutal are you willing to be isn't it? Yeah, it's basically how moderate, you know, moderate versus radicals to some extent. So I think, yes, so I think that a bunch of kind of, you know, centrist dads were never going to... That's a big... We're never going to kick off the Russian Revolution.
真正的……嗯，那将是一场完全不同的革命，汤姆，你觉得呢？嗯，我认为，我的意思是，布尔什维克和孟什维克之间的区别本质上是你愿意变得多么残忍，不是吗？是的，基本上在某种程度上是温和派与激进派的区别。所以我认为，是的，所以我认为一群，你知道，中间派的爸爸们永远不会……这是一个很大的……我们永远不会发动俄国革命。
I mean, the Bolsheviks, the Russian Revolution... It's the brutality. You said the violence is baked in. And yet the irony, right, the ambiguity, is the Bolsheviks succeed because the one thing they offer is peace. Everybody else pretty much is arguing for Russia to carry on in the First World War in the summer of 1917. And the Bolsheviks make progress, particularly among the army,
我的意思是，布尔什维克，俄国革命……这是残忍。你说暴力是根深蒂固的。然而讽刺的是，对吧，这种模糊性在于，布尔什维克成功了，因为他们提供的一件事是和平。在1917年夏天，几乎所有其他人都在争论俄罗斯是否应该继续参加第一次世界大战。而布尔什维克取得了进展，特别是在军队中，
because they're the ones who are saying, no, we'll have peace with Germany, we'll stop fighting straight away. And all their rivals are sort of shilly-shallying and saying, well, we're still committed to the Allies. So the Bolsheviks win by saying peace, but also they're prepared to be more extreme. They're always prepared to go further than anybody else. And so, of course, if anybody else had been, you know, if Kerensky had stayed in power, then yes, the history of the 20th century would look, I mean, it would look very different, I think. Similar dialectic going on with um trotsky
因为他们是那些说，不，我们将与德国实现和平，我们将立即停止战斗的人。而他们所有的竞争对手都在犹豫不决，说，嗯，我们仍然致力于盟国。所以布尔什维克通过说和平赢得了胜利，但他们也准备变得更加极端。他们总是准备比任何人都走得更远。所以，当然，如果其他人，你知道，如果克伦斯基继续掌权，那么是的，20世纪的历史看起来，我的意思是，看起来会非常不同，我想。托洛茨基和斯大林之间也有类似的辩证法，
and stalin and stalin ultimately wins out again because he essentially weirdly offers you know peace and and uh stability whereas trotsky is all about permanent revolution and well trotsky is a loose cannon isn't he he's a completely loose cannon and um yes stalin is stalin's the second i mean stalin is the secretary he is the boring guy in the meetings. He's done all the paperwork. I love the idea that both Lenin and Stalin are the kind of safe stable. Anyway, Liz J, great question here. Would a non-communist Russia have been able to resist and ultimately defeat Nazi Germany? Or was it the unique nature of being a communist state that allowed it to fight the war with such brutal force and disregard for human life? That's a great question. And you've just
而斯大林最终胜出，再次因为他本质上奇怪地提供了，你知道，和平与稳定，而托洛茨基全是关于不断革命，嗯，托洛茨基是个不可预测的人，不是吗？他完全是个不可预测的人，嗯，是的，斯大林是……斯大林是秘书，他是会议上那个无聊的家伙。他完成了所有的文书工作。我喜欢列宁和斯大林都是那种安全、稳定的人的想法。总之，莉兹·J（Liz J），这里有个好问题。一个非共产主义的俄罗斯能够抵御并最终击败纳粹德国吗？还是说正是作为共产主义国家的独特本质，才使它能够以如此残酷的武力和对人命的漠视来打这场战争？这是一个好问题。你刚刚
written a review of a book on Stalin's war, haven't you? I have. Yeah, a very extraordinary book actually by a man called Sean McMeekin. Now, McMeekin, he has this great idea. It's a brilliant central idea of, you know, let's, instead of thinking about the war just about Hitler, we should think about it through, you know. Stalin is the key to the war, not Hitler. So Stalin, look at it through Russia's point of view. It's Russia that also invades Poland. Russia swallows up the Baltic states. Japan is largely motivated by fear of Russia,
写了一篇关于斯大林战争的书评，不是吗？是的。确实是一本非常非凡的书，作者是一个叫肖恩·麦克米金（Sean McMeekin）的人。现在，麦克米金，他有一个伟大的想法。这是一个绝妙的核心思想，你知道，让我们不要只把战争看作是关于希特勒的，我们应该通过，你知道，斯大林是战争的关键，而不是希特勒。所以斯大林，从俄罗斯的角度来看。也是俄罗斯入侵了波兰。俄罗斯吞并了波罗的海国家。日本很大程度上是出于对俄罗斯的恐惧，
so Russia allows you to tie together sort of the Eastern Western theatres, the Pacific and the European theatres of the war. But he also has this extraordinary argument, which slightly to me, well, fatally undermines his book, which is that the Allies should have attacked Stalin as well as Hitler. So we should have, having declared war on Hitler about Poland, we should then have declared war on Stalin when Stalin went into Finland.
所以俄罗斯让你把战争的东线和西线、太平洋和欧洲战区联系在一起。但他也有这个非凡的论点，这对我来说，嗯，致命地削弱了他的书，那就是盟军应该同时攻击斯大林和希特勒。所以我们应该，在因为波兰问题对希特勒宣战后，当斯大林进入芬兰时，我们也应该对斯大林宣战。
We should have fought in defence of Finland. He thinks that Britain and France, if we'd fought Stalin in Finland, that Roosevelt would have joined in, which I don't think he would, and that Mussolini would have joined in on our side as well. So that would be a very different segment. Anyway. You're slurring me off there. That was entirely my fault.
我们应该为保卫芬兰而战。他认为英国和法国，如果我们为了芬兰与斯大林作战，罗斯福也会加入，我不认为他会，而且墨索里尼也会站在我们这边加入。所以那将是一个非常不同的片段。总之。你在诋毁我。那完全是我的错。
You took me down the wrong course. Would a non-communist Russia... Maybe not, actually. I mean, the nature of communism meant that you could discipline and control Would a non-communist Russia? Maybe not, actually. I mean, the nature of communism meant that you could discipline and control millions of people. And as you say, it's the idea of sacrificing people in the name of the greater good. That sort of came naturally to Stalin's commanders
你把我带到了错误的轨道上。一个非共产主义的俄罗斯……也许不会，实际上。我的意思是，共产主义的本质意味着你可以纪律和控制数百万的人。正如你所说，这是以更大利益的名义牺牲人们的想法。这在斯大林的指挥官们看来是很自然的，
and the sort of no-step-back rule that the Soviet commissars were always sort of drumming into their offices. I mean, that feels very Stalinist. And military historians, people like Max Hastings, will say the Russians were prepared to do whatever it took and pay any price. When British generals or American generals were a bit weedy about sacrificing their men, Stalin's generals knew that basically if they didn't sacrifice their men, they'd be shot themselves. So they were very effective in that sense. Wasn't the same thing going on with Napoleon's invasion of Russia, though?
以及苏联政委总是向他们的军官灌输的那种“不许后退”的规则。我的意思是，这感觉非常斯大林主义。军事历史学家，像马克斯·黑斯廷斯（Max Hastings）这样的人，会说俄罗斯人准备好不惜一切代价，付出任何代价。当英国将军或美国将军在牺牲士兵方面有点软弱时，斯大林的将军们知道，基本上如果他们不牺牲士兵，他们自己就会被枪毙。所以他们在那种意义上非常有效。拿破仑入侵俄罗斯时不是也发生了同样的事情吗？
Well, yeah, that's the argument. And, of course, in the First World War, the Tsarist officers treated their men like absolute... Yeah, cannon fodder. Also, I mean, it's when the nazis invade that um stalin slightly resurrects some of the old traditions of russia orthodoxy he's yeah he sends well he sends an icon up in a plane that yeah flies around uh the city limits of moscow so that's stalin stalin's a much underestimated politician because he's much more flexible than let's say hitler is he's cannier than hitler and i think you're right about there's always this people often forget about russia that as recently as the sort of mid to late 19th century about 40 million russians have been surfed they're
嗯，是的，那是那个论点。而且，当然，在第一次世界大战中，沙皇军官对待他们的士兵就像绝对的……是的，炮灰。此外，我的意思是，当纳粹入侵时，斯大林稍微复兴了一些俄罗斯东正教的旧传统。他，是的，他派了一个圣像上飞机，绕着莫斯科市界飞行，所以那是斯大林。斯大林是一个被严重低估的政治家，因为他比希特勒灵活得多，他比希特勒更精明，而且我认为你是对的，关于俄罗斯，人们经常忘记，就在19世纪中后期，大约4000万俄罗斯人还是农奴，他们
basically made slaves so this sort of violence and inequality was kind of was was baked into russia stalinism or no stalinism okay okay i think we've got time for one more question golly um do you want to do the the space question yes so this is richard goldstein and he asks if technology continues to rapidly improve isn't a communistic system inevitable for earthlings in a thousand years if not a hundred years when there is no barrier to material well-being wouldn't competition dependent livelihoods become obsolete there's a lot of communism in science fiction. I love the fact that Richard Goldstein may not himself be human when he talks about earthlings. Yeah, there is, you're right.
基本上被当作奴隶，所以这种暴力和不平等在俄罗斯是根深蒂固的，无论有没有斯大林主义。好吧，好吧，我想我们还有时间回答最后一个问题。天哪，嗯，你想回答那个太空问题吗？是的，这是理查德·戈尔茨坦（Richard Goldstein），他问如果技术继续快速进步，对于地球人来说，在一百年甚至一千年后，当物质福祉没有障碍时，共产主义制度难道不是不可避免的吗？竞争依赖的生计难道不会过时吗？科幻小说中有很多共产主义。我喜欢理查德·戈尔茨坦在谈论地球人时可能自己不是人类的事实。是的，你是对的。
And there was a communist group called the Positists. The Positists, Dennis Healy complained about in his memoirs that he was being heckled. The Positists were supporting Tony Benn in the Labour deputy leadership election of 1981. The Positists believe supporting Tony Benn in the Labour deputy leadership election of 1981. The Positists believe that because communism is the future, and because it's the future and it's historically inevitable, communism is identified with technological modernity.
有一个叫波萨达斯主义者（Posadists）的共产主义团体。波萨达斯主义者，丹尼斯·希利（Dennis Healy）在他的回忆录中抱怨他被起哄。波萨达斯主义者在1981年工党副领袖选举中支持托尼·本（Tony Benn）。波萨达斯主义者认为，因为共产主义是未来，而且因为它是未来，在历史上是不可避免的，共产主义与技术现代性是等同的。
The Positists believe that if there were any other civilizations in the universe that were more advanced than us, they would, by definition, have to be communist. So they thought the revolution would probably be brought and they still do think the revolution will probably be brought to to earth by people and flying saucers who will impress us with their communism and then we'll convert us we'll come you know we'll all become communists i don't find that very plausible uh and i don't find richard goldstein argument very... I don't think it will become inevitable, actually. I think it goes against human nature. You brought up Tony Benn.
波萨达斯主义者认为，如果宇宙中还有其他比我们更先进的文明，它们根据定义必须是共产主义的。所以他们认为革命很可能会被带来，而且他们仍然认为革命很可能会被乘坐飞碟的人带到地球，他们会用他们的共产主义给我们留下深刻印象，然后我们会皈依，我们会，你知道，我们都会成为共产主义者。我不觉得这很可信，而且我不觉得理查德·戈尔茨坦的论点很……我不认为它会变得不可避免，实际上。我认为这违背了人性。你提到了托尼·本。
Yeah. Who I learned from your book got stung on the penis by a wasp. In the bath? I think when he was gardening, wasn't it? But a kind of interesting parallel to Marx, who had a huge boil on his penis and wrote to Engels about it. So there you go. Great heroes.
是的。我从你的书中得知他被黄蜂蜇了阴茎。在浴缸里？我想是在他园艺的时候，不是吗？但这与马克思有一个有趣的相似之处，马克思阴茎上长了一个巨大的疖子，并写信给恩格斯谈论它。所以你看。伟大的英雄。
This is what happens. This is what happens. Great heroes of socialism. Left wing of the spectrum, isn't it? When you get into that world, boils follow. Brilliant. Well, I think the gravedigger of our podcast has... Time is the gravedigger of our podcast. I think this sort of highbr our podcast is... Time is the grave digger of our podcast.
这就是发生的事情。这就是发生的事情。社会主义的伟大英雄。左翼光谱，不是吗？当你进入那个世界时，疖子就会随之而来。太棒了。嗯，我想我们播客的掘墓人已经……时间是我们播客的掘墓人。我想这种高深莫测的分析正是结束关于马克思主义对话所需要的。嗯，共产主义在国际上基本上已经被叫停了。今天我们也一样。提醒一下，周四我们将和特雷西·博曼（Tracy Borman）谈论伊丽莎白一世。所以你永远不能指责我们
I think this sort of highbrow analysis is precisely what is needed to close the conversation about Marxism forever. Well, time has been largely called on communism internationally. It's been called on us too today. A reminder that on Thursday, we're talking about Elizabeth I with Tracy Borman. So you can't ever accuse us
在这个播客上兴趣范围太窄。总之，感谢收听，享受革命，很快再见，再见。感谢收听《历史的其余部分》，获取奖励剧集、抢先收听、无广告收听以及访问我们的聊天室。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。
of having too narrow a field of interest on this podcast anyway thank you for listening enjoy the revolution and see you soon bye thanks for listening to the rest is history for bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
无论如何，感谢您收听本播客，感谢您对我们兴趣范围过于狭窄的包容。享受这场革命，我们很快再见，再见。感谢您收听《历史的余韵》。如需收听奖励剧集、抢先体验、无广告收听以及参与我们的聊天，请查看相关内容。本集暂无评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。